Last week's sit down with Brigitte Gabriel
received quite possibly the most positive
reaction we've ever had to an interview.
I'd say well over 90% of the responses that
I saw on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook were
appreciative off our discussion of her incredible
story growing up in Lebanon during the civil
war, about the roots of radical Islam, and
what living in a free society is really all
about.
People were in awe of Brigitte's personal
story, amazed by her passion, impressed by
her candor, or some combination thereof.
If you haven't seen her episode yet, but you
only have a few minutes, just check out the
last 5 minutes of our chat to see what true
love of freedom and liberty is all about.
We'll put the link to that right here in the
description.
And, for the record, I wasn't tearing up because
of her impassioned speech, it was these damn
bright lights were getting to me!
Yes, yes, that's it, these damned bright lights.
I mention the reaction to our interview with
Brigitte because it reiterates a lesson I've
consistently learned by doing this show.
Before we had Brigitte on, I talked to my
team about whether we should have her on at
all.
After all, Brigitte is hated by a lot of people
who call her the usual buzzwords like racist,
bigot, far right extremist, and so on.
While we all know the people who are using
these words are becoming the new boy who cried
wolf, and these words themselves are losing
their meaning by the minute, the chill effect
these words have still remains in certain
quarters.
Even in my case, when I'm selecting guests,
I do have to think for a moment if there's
going to be some sort of cost for me to sit
down with someone.
I still get plenty of hate for talking to
Milo, Mike Cernovich, Tommy Robinson, Paul
Joseph Watson and some others.
In none of those cases do I regret having
the conversations, regardless of the blowback
these interviews may have caused me, but it
does bring to light an important topic.
It's not just those who are being targeted
as bigots and racists who are in the firing
line of those who would like to silence us.
It's also the people willing to talk to those
people and hear them out.
This guilt by association is incredibly dangerous
because it can bite any of us for having a
family member, or even a friendship, with
someone who shares political views that fall
out of the mainstream.
Should we disown people with views different
than ours?
Defame them?
Publicly humiliate them?
All of these are small steps towards reporting
them to the authorities for wrongthink.
We should also note in the online word, there
is an information battle constantly happening.
When you put Brigitte's name in Google, the
first site that comes up which isn't one of
her own is to islamophobia.org, which is part
of CAIR, the council on American Islamic Relations.
Now think back to my interview with Brigitte.
What was the bigoted part?
After living through everything she has, does
she strike you as the problem in society?
Does she strike you as a bigot or a racist
or a right wing nut?
What I think is most interesting about the
assault on conversation is how recent this
phenomenon is.
My friend and mentor Larry King has built
his legendary career on talking to people
from every walk of life and from every part
of the world.
On 5 days of any given week he could talk
to a member of the Ku Klux Klan, then Louis
Farrakhan, then the cast of Friends, then
Magic Johnson and then the Pope.
Nobody ever accused him of sharing all of
their beliefs just because he talked to all
of them.
Actually, this very concept would've been
totally ludicrous.
I'm proud to say that I know Larry pretty
well, and it's his curious mind and real sense
of wonder that made and still make him want
to talk to all sorts of people doing all sorts
of different things.
As you know my policy is that sunlight is
the best disinfectant -- people with bad ideas
will eventually hang themselves if given even
room to do so, which I always try to do.
This growing sense of guilt by association
is just the next level of what the Regressive
Left has done.
It's not enough to just label someone a bigot
anymore, now we have to tar and feather them
so other people will be afraid to talk to
them as well.
And if you're willing to talk to someone out
of their accepted group, they'll tar and feather
you as well to shut down any furthering of
the conversation.
And yes, unfortunately, I do see this phenomenon
far more on the left than on the right.
It's almost as if when you cut through the
hysteria and screaming and slandering they
don't even believe their own ideas.
So they don't want counter ideas heard, but
they also want to make sure people aren't
entertaining other ideas in the first place.
This is incredibly dangerous and it's not
a game that I'll be taking part of.
We can't give them an inch because they will
keep taking and taking until there is nothing
of us left.
Between this silencing of those who veer from
the mainstream and the YouTube demonetization
I discuss last week, those of us who really
are fighting for free speech have our work
cut out for us.
Fortunately, we're continuing out partnership
with Learn Liberty this week and joining me
is assistant professor of economics at the
University of Tampa Abby Hall.
Abby is also a affiliates scholar at the Mercatus
Institute and a research fellow with the Independent
Institute, a non partisan educational think
tank.
We're going to talk economics, war and peace,
the drug war, our militarized police and much
more.
I'll gladly accept my guilt by association
to her, and we'll see how it goes as to whether
she can say the same about me.